muchas gracias por la invitación en el
nombre de la relación americana de
organizaciones no gubernamentales de
personas con discapacidad y familias
para la cual trabajó como oficial de
derechos humanos en realidad las medidas
han sido muy poco incluyentes se ha
tratado de responder rápidamente a la
pandemia entiendo yo que es porque
ningún gobierno estaba preparado pero
también creo que es momento de comenzar
a pensar estas medidas han iniciado por
ejemplo la falta de datos desglosados
por discapacidad por lo cual muchas
veces no se ha podido dar una respuesta
oportuna a las necesidades de las
personas con discapacidad sin embargo
algo también muy importante es que
sociedad civil ha podido también
manifestarse expresar pronunciamientos y
también colaborar para que esta pandemia
trate de que estas barreras no sean
demasiadas para las personas con
discapacidad sin embargo si esté todavía
un riesgo de que todos los derechos que
sean conquistados el momento pueden
retroceder y por lo tanto tenemos que
trabajar mucho en esta etapa de
reactivación y reconstrucción
precisamente señora galarza que deben
priorizar los gobiernos y los
involucrados para mejorar la situación
de las personas con capacidades
diferentes
lo que hay que progresar en el caso de
personas con discapacidad hay que hablar
de un enfoque de doble vía primero poner
en el centro el modelo social de
derechos humanos en la cual se incorpore
decir se transversales en la
discapacidad en todos los ámbitos
sociales educativos de empleo e salud
pero a la vez se hagan intervenciones
específicas porque hay necesidades
específicas propias de las personas con
discapacidad se debe garantizar la
accesibilidad de la información en todo
formato en todo momento y sobre todo es
necesario mecanismos de consulta para
que las personas con discapacidad
podamos participar desde el diseño
evaluación implementación de toda
política y programa social
rosario- galarza muchas gracias por sus
palabras y está la comunicación ella es
integrante de la red latinoamericana de
organizaciones no gubernamentales de
personas con discapacidad y sus familias